[Music]
all right everybody welcome my name is
David Eustace I'm a software engineer on
Google cloud I'm here with my colleagues
ken Owens and Conrad DeLong and the
topic for the talk today is about
developing applications on kubernetes so
first off by show of hands who here has
heard of kubernetes that's good yeah
because the word has probably been
mentioned a few times at this conference
all right hands up again if you've at
least played around with kubernetes
maybe taken a tutorial all right how
about if you're using kubernetes on a
daily basis great so we got the whole
range here today we are going to be
covering some of the basic building
blocks of developing applications on
kubernetes but there should also be some
new information for everyone about how
to take advantage of the new application
resource that we've been working on to
think about applications as a more
holistic unit in kubernetes so with
kubernetes you can manage computing
resources so that's about scheduling
containers onto cluster of servers but I
think like one of the reasons that
kubernetes has been so successful is it
doesn't just do that it also helps you
manage other types of infrastructure
specifically networking and storage so
if you're building any or most kinds of
real-world applications you need to
configure some amount of networking for
example configuring service discovery so
that as your containers are moving
around in the cluster they can find each
other or load balancers or firewall
rules on the storage side this is about
where your application data lives at
rest for performance reasons you might
want that storage in a locally attached
SSD or you might want it on a network
attached file system so that it could be
more dynamically accessed so you need to
be thinking about all these things when
you're developing applications for the
cloud and
kubernetes has a really nice construct
for doing this which we call
infrastructure as code in this example
there's a resource here called a PUD if
you're not familiar with that that's
okay the important thing is this is a
simple configuration file and it lives
in source code and so it's in source
code along with all the other
application code that you're developing
for your application and that means you
can use all of your existing source
control tools for revision control and
code review and release and that's
really great from a management
perspective and if you need to be
controlling networking storage
infrastructure at the same time that's
just more of these configuration files
and then when you're ready when you want
to push an instance of your application
to kubernetes you just upload the config
to kubernetes and it's going to manage
the underlying infrastructure for you so
these configs are in the language of
kubernetes and kubernetes knows how to
manage underlying infrastructure
wherever that might be on google cloud
or on-premise um where else and so that
means as an application developer you
don't actually have to think about where
your application is going to be running
in production you can just target
kubernetes so what about deploying a
whole application what does that look
like so these days there are actually
some pretty nice tools in the ecosystem
for this helm is one such tool and the
helm community has done a really great
job of packaging up all many common
open-source software stacks that you
might want to be using on kubernetes so
with a command like this these days you
know once you set up your cluster and
set up helm and and maybe a few other
things you actually can install
WordPress with with a single command
like this which feels pretty good or I
thought this was pretty cool when I
first saw it but then what you end up
with is a little bit intimidating
especially if you're new to kubernetes
or or you're installing it off-the-shelf
app and you don't really know how it's
all put together and what you're seeing
here is basically the list of resources
and these are the resources we need to
configure all that infrastructure but at
this point in my journey of using this
application I probably don't need to see
all this
and something seems to be missing here
basically like where's WordPress is the
problem and what I mean by that
specifically if I just ran this command
a second ago chances are it's not ready
yet there's some sort of installation
progress that needs to happen even in
the cloud provisioning this
infrastructure takes time and we do have
that list of resources so what's their
status once the thing is up and running
you need to connect to it so if it's a
web hosting application that might mean
connecting to a URL for the site or the
admin console if it's a back-end service
you need a quick link to the service
endpoint the credentials maybe some
client commands or tools for for smoke
testing the the application and then
that's really where the process just
begins because now you need to customize
the application for your use case and
for that you probably need a link to the
user guide maybe some quick instructions
for the most common operational tasks
like performing upgrades backups restore
or deletion so that's the general
problem that we're trying to tackle with
the application resource and for that so
just a quick note on the agenda so we're
going to introduce the kubernetes
application resource we're going to talk
about how we've been integrating
applications into google kubernetes
engine which is Google's hosted
kubernetes offering and we're also going
to talk about how you can get started
with these apps quickly in the Google
cloud platform marketplace so I will
hand it over to Ken Owens
Thanks give it
hi I'm Ken Owen so I'm a software
engineer on google kubernetes engine I
work on the workloads team and in the
open-source community I'm a contributor
and co-chair of kubernetes sig
applications
so as you contributor to sing
applications obviously I spend a lot of
my time thinking about apps so to start
with I want to talk about some of the
things that go into applications and
from a show of hands most of you are
familiar with kubernetes some of you I
see how many people are using it in
production right now substantial
fraction so some of this might be a
little bit of overview but for some of
you this kind of is necessary to
understand what's going on with a demo
later
so pod a pod is basically an atom of
scheduling it's a set of containers some
volumes and the compute resources mem
CPU to go along with that kubernetes is
the declan a rake if declaratory P I so
when you create a pod you specify those
things and the system goes ahead and
make sure that pod gets scheduled and
created as you specified it there we go
so volumes volumes are how your pods if
they have durable storage right things
to disk they mount inside of the
container and it just appears in the
file system now if you want it to be
durable if it's not an empty turf you
don't want it to disappear then you need
to have a PV PV is a persistent volume
on Google Cloud that's backed by Google
persistent disk TVs don't disappear with
the pod if you want to schedule a PV if
you want to actually provision one and
not the into a pod use a persistent
volume claim and all that's well and
good but ultimately even if you've got
your compute if you've got your storage
if you've got your memory your CPU you
need to get network traffic to the pod
in order to do that you use a service
this is basically your atom of
networking so a service basically just
programs a network to route traffic to a
pod and if you want to expose it
externally you can do that on our cloud
that'll provision a load balancer for
you
so those basic core resources are like
the primitives that you use to turn up a
workload on kubernetes but they're not
really interesting I mean most workloads
don't consists of a single pod and most
people don't want to go through the
exercise of managing pods individually
that's where the workloads api's come in
so the most basic and it's not really
that basic any more resource for
scheduling many pods our deployments and
replica sets now these are for your
stateless 12 factor applications when
you create it again it's a declaratory 8
a deployment you say I want n PI's and I
want them to have this container and
want them to have this many resources
the system's gonna go ahead and schedule
those pods for you now it can roll them
out concurrently meaning if you create
like five pods you may get to created at
a time if you scale that down if you say
you know what I don't want five pods
anymore I'd like three pods it may kill
two of them simultaneously and that's
fairly desirable you want to be able to
accelerate rollouts for stateless
serving applications but not so much for
databases
that's where stateful sets come in so
stateful sets are an attempt to help you
build applications run workloads that
contain things like databases or other
distributed storage systems or other
distributed systems in general message
queues Kafka whatever you like
and we found that they required some
additional semantics around them so for
stateful sets it'll do rollouts as well
but it rolls them out one at a time
meaning that when you get pod one pod
two doesn't come up until pod one says
okay I'm ready you can put traffic on me
when you tear it down you don't tear
down pop one until pod two says okay I'm
done whatever I had to do to clean up
it's happened you can take me down you
can move on to my next guy and other
than that the pods also have durable
provision storage and a durable network
identity and when that means is let's
say a pod dies when the pod comes back
it's gonna have the same network
identity that it had before and that's
in terms of DNS the IP address may
change but again using DNS it's
generally enough to be able to identify
that pod correctly more importantly
potentially it's going to have the same
storage so if you wrote something to a
disk
PAH blends disk when it comes back is
going to be the same disk and I'll be
able to retrieve it storage and lastly
you've got demon sets so some very
complicated apps like say distributed
file systems we might want to do
something like deploy an ode to urban
sorry deploy a pod to every node in the
cluster so if you're familiar with HDFS
and you're deploying like a data node
you want to select the subset of nodes
and say I want to date a node on all of
these it's kind of a different paradigm
from just replication which is what
deployments and staple sites are good at
and daemon sets are good for that so now
we've talked about all these resources
but David kind of made it very explicit
before this is kind of hard to manage
like you take all of these things and
plug them together and at the end of the
day it's really kind of hard to have a
unified view of what your application
actually is moreover all the tools in
the ecosystem kind of have a slightly
DEP and different definition of an
application so insig apps but we set out
to do sorry I missed this config maps
and secrets are also something you see
commonly they're just basically storage
for your configuration values map of
keys to an app of values and the
difference between comping maps and
secrets is primarily that secrets are
encrypted and you also might see some
ingress as layer ingress is effectively
route traffic into the cluster and
they're used for firewall rules they'll
do TLS termination and they work at
layer seven so back to what I was saying
before so insig apps we started thinking
about well how can we defragment this
how can we make sure that case on it and
helm both look at an app the same way
and that the gke UI and the tectonic UI
and the openshift UI i'll start looking
at an app in the same way so all the
resources that we talked about before
they're nothing special right they ship
with kubernetes by default but
kubernetes provides you a mechanism to
extend the API to have your own
resources and those resources aren't any
different in any meaningful way from the
resources that we ship with a
distribution so sig app set around say
ok well let's come up with a resource
that represents an application let's
figure out what that looks like and
let's do it with the consensus of the
community so that we don't have twenty
of them we have one no we're not going
to ship it by default with kubernetes
but anybody who wants to use it and
primarily in cig apps we have a lot of
tool vendors tool builders and UI
designers they'll be able to use it and
we don't have to reinvent the wheel from
scratch every time so it should promote
interoperability and reduce low the
level of effort that developers have to
put into thinking about this so what it
really does is it just groups resources
describes the application and provides a
set of properties about the application
that are configurable on a per instance
basis so the resource metadata is just
the same metadata that you see with
every kubernetes object pods have them
staple sets have them it basically just
identifies the metadata of the
application itself and of that instance
so the descriptor now the descriptor
groups information about the application
kind I guess you would say right so
let's say you have a MySQL application
the descriptor from MySQL probably isn't
going to change much it contains things
like links to documentation the
maintainer of the application or the
maintainer --zz of the underlying code
some notes about the application then
we've info items so info items are
individual to a specific instance of the
application so this has things like the
administrative password for the app a
reference to Secrets which is the same
thing IP addresses credentials endpoints
and other contact values that are
specific to an instance of the
application and lastly this is kind of
the magic part is the grouping of the
individual resources so what this is
actually saying is okay I produce
stateful sets back combined with the
label selector that's in the application
allows any UI any tool to be able to go
find all the things that are in that
application and you'll see this in the
demo that's coming up next it allows you
to build you eyes consistently and
allows anyone to build you eyes
that are able to discover all the things
that are in an application and present
it to you in a way that's meaningful and
application-specific and next we've got
a demo from my colleague Conrad think
you can hello my name is Conrad DeLong
I'm a software engineer on Google Cloud
I work on the cloud console team and I'm
going to tell you about how you're
making use of the application resource
and google kubernetes engine so if you
are not familiar with google kubernetes
engine let me quickly go through that
it's a hosted coverity solution by
Google it's the most mature hosted
kubernetes solution out there it's been
GA for several years now it fully
manages your clusters and that includes
both the control plane as well as the
notes it offers additional features like
logging monitoring audit logging and it
comes with a very nice built-in UI which
I'm going to show you in a minute so in
this demo I will first introduce an
example application then I will walk
over all the resources that this
application consists of and then I will
show how using the application resource
brings them all together so let's jump
to the demo demo please
so what you see in this page is a list
of all the workloads running in my
communities fleet and under the name
column you'll be able to find the
front-end and the two and the two
elements of the Redis actually let's
switch back to the slides for a moment
yeah before I show you the demo I want
to talk more about the app first so the
app consists of two components the
front-end which is a PHP application and
back-end which is the database which is
Redis and the read is itself it is split
into two parts on its own there is the
Redis master and
data holding ready replicas each of
those is potentially replicated so
you'll see there are three replicas for
the front end there are two replicas for
the data holding register because in
this single read is master all that is
exposed to the public internet using
servers of a kind load balancer so in
this chart the every rectangle
corresponds to a kubernetes pod every
column of rectangles corresponds to Q
Bernese deployments and these finding
out connections are Q Bernese services
so if we use an application and just
send it to our kubernetes api plane we
will be able to manifest the information
that all these resources belong together
and have it'll show them for us so now
let's switch to the demo so the front
and the two red aces that i talked about
you can see them here they're in them
under the name column you'll see the
front end to the two red aces under the
parts column you will see the number of
replicas so you'll see that there's
three one and two respectively and the
same goes for the services list you can
see the front end is the only one that's
exposed to the public internet so I can
actually go and visit that IP address
and our two registers living there apart
from that there is also a piece of
configuration it is a secret called my
secret which holds the credentials
needed to connect to the register
database so now let's have a look at the
applications dashboard so in this page
you can see the list of all the
applications running in my fleet or one
of them and you can already see that
there is some information useful for
humans to understand what's going on so
there's things like name of the software
and version
the software it is not used by any
machines it is for you to understand
what's going on and if we open it we
will see all these components that we
had to hunt for before they are listed
right there
on the right hand side you will see the
description instructions for what to do
after the installation and links to
documentation and over around the middle
in the info box you will find the
structures information regarding this
specific instance of the application so
you'll be able to reach out to that
service again you can even type
something here and you can also access
the secret data that you have stored
somewhere else and again this is just
like any other kubernetes resource so if
we open so we can preview it ya know and
it's alright there it is
it holds all the information needed to
render this page ok back to the slides
please thank you so David mentioned helm
before and you will you might be
wondering how this relates with helm and
the answer is it's fully compatible it
is just another cue Bernese resource
kind so if we need to if we want to make
use of it
we just extend our helm chart this is an
example list file for an example ham
chart with a template for generating
applications and then the installation
changes from this to that and you just
notice that there is this new
application resource getting deployed so
after you run this you will get this
useful overview of your application for
your own applications just like that so
if you are the only author of your
application
and you have like two workloads running
there this is a nice to have really but
it's it really comes
when there are several teams in your
company and you want to pass information
between each other
and it becomes really critical when your
applications come from third party so to
tell you more about that I'll pass the
mic back to David who will tell me about
google cloud marketplace
thanks Conrad so yeah now that we've
seen a little bit about the building
blocks of applications and the new
application resource and its
capabilities I want to show you the
what's probably the quickest way to get
started with applications using the
Google cloud platform marketplace if
you're not familiar with the GCP
marketplace this is a product that's
actually been around for several years
it was formerly called cloud launcher
and what you'll find there is a catalog
with literally hundreds of solutions for
whatever kind of problem you're trying
to solve on GCP all of these solutions
have been vetted and tested by us and
we've made us Minister effort to make
sure you can get started with these
quickly usually just with a few clicks
through the console some of these
solutions are built by Google you those
are usually kind of the open source
stacks that are really popular and we
just want GCP customers have a great
experience using those but actually the
majority of these solutions come from
our third-party partners and we have
contracts with all of these partners to
provide long-term and maintenance and
support of these solutions so again you
know if you're finding solutions in the
marketplace you're gonna have a good
time using those traditionally we've
mostly had two types of products in the
marketplace one based on virtual
machines so partners provide virtual
machine images deployment manager
configurations if you're familiar with
that we also have some managed services
in the marketplace but we're excited to
have announced just this past week that
we're adding a first-class support for
kubernetes in the marketplace and we're
actually the first public cloud
marketplace to have this capability
[Applause]
but backing up for a second why would we
do this
in marketplace I mean we already have
all these hundreds of virtual machine
solutions and they work great but we
actually think there there's some
reasons that containers and kubernetes
are a better way to distribute software
especially packaged software and
commercial software so if you're a
software vendor up there in the audience
or an enterprise consuming commercial
software that this parts for you and
take notice because I think this is
going to be an important trend so first
of all we all know that containers are
portable so if you if you find a virtual
machine image from our marketplace and
then you try and install it on Prem
you're probably going to have a hard
time with that
but that's exactly what containers would
allow you to do and similarly for
kubernetes like I mentioned when you're
building an application for kubernetes
you don't need to worry necessarily
about where that infrastructure where
the application is going to be running
at the end of the day so that's also
portable so if you think about that for
a moment that means if you find one of
these solutions in the marketplace you
can deploy it onto Google Cloud but you
can also take those exact same assets
and deploy it onto kubernetes wherever
kubernetes is running containers are
also much lighter weight than virtual
machines
so a typical container image might be a
few megabytes for virtual machines
that's like gigabytes and this makes a
big difference when you're trying to
rapidly scale up scale down to respond
to traffic it's also great from the
commercial vendors perspective because
what they're shipping to the customer is
really just their own application binary
its immediate runtime dependencies not
the whole operating system and that's
also great for marketplace customers
because they probably don't want that
operating system in their production
fleet they want to be using their own
golden vetted host operating system that
their IT department has given them and
then of course we've seen with all these
great primitives and kubernetes that
containers
a lot of built-in management
functionality for scaling for rollouts
for failure recovery it's just much
easier to manage lots of these
containers with kubernetes and then it
is to do the same thing with virtual
machines and since this is a marketplace
and we and we do have energy at
enterprise grade commercial solutions I
want to mention that some of these
kubernetes applications have integrated
billing so what does that mean first of
all it's pay-as-you-go pricing which is
what you be familiar with in the cloud
that just means the more you use
something the more you pay if you shut
it down entirely you're not going to pay
anything anymore you're gonna get one
bill from Google so as an enterprise
customer you don't need to have a
commercial enterprise agreement with
each of these vendors we've done that
work for you and the bills the fees will
just show up on your Google cloud
platform bill one thing that we've done
that's really interesting with these
applications is we're able to support a
custom pricing metrics so that means the
pricing for the application is really
tailored to the application so for
example if it's a database application
the pricing might be based on storage or
if it's a CI CD application the pricing
might be based on the number of builds
or the number of deployments and this
works a lot better than kind of trying
to squeeze all of these commercial
applications into a one-size-fits-all
billing metric like core ours was what
we've traditionally used for virtual
machines and then importantly because we
want all this to be portable the
metering system that we've designed for
this is cloud agnostic and that means
the metering will happen whether the
containers are running on GCP or whether
they're running somewhere else and to
show you a little bit how that works
essentially the applications themselves
are generating billing metrics they're
reporting those metrics to a Google
managed reporting endpoint and
identifying the customer billing account
when they make those reports and so then
at the end of the month Google tallies
up all the usage bills the customer pays
the vendor
and that's pretty much how it works so
we're really excited to have some of the
top-tier third-party software vendors
working with us for the introduction of
these commercial kubernetes applications
some of these names you should be
familiar with you can see that this
really spans a wide range of computing
categories from databases to security
applications see ICD logging monitoring
I think this is kind of a testament to
the power of kubernetes itself to be
able to support all these different
types of distributed workloads and we're
really excited to have seen all the
excitement from these vendors
I think they've understood the kind of
new wave of containers and kubernetes
for a commercial software distribution
and and it's come through here so thanks
to all of our partners so I'm gonna jump
over to a demo real quick just show you
how easy it is to actually use these
from consoles so here I am in the Google
cloud platform console UI or in the
kubernetes section have a couple of
clusters running here but not much else
is running in this cluster so I'll go
over to the applications section that
Conrad was showing you and click deploy
from marketplace and so right away I've
got a catalog here
with currently 27 solutions that'll be
growing all the time different computing
categories are available here if I open
one of these for example aerospike
aerospike is a flash optimized no sequel
database you can see in this case I've
already purchased a plan the pricing is
based on storage hours whoops
thank you
but I won't deploy aerospike right now
let's go take a look we've got some
other great solutions here from aqua
this is a security application they have
a couple different pricing metrics based
on the size of the nodes that are being
monitored for this security application
but I think I will deploy an instance of
RabbitMQ so that's a distributing as
distributed message queue system this
one happens to be packaged by Google and
so it's free to use you just pay for
your usage of kubernetes we have let's
see so if I go to configure this so
right now it's got my one of my clusters
selected I could switch to a different
cluster if I wanted to but I'll just
keep the defaults here there's some
custom properties that I could configure
so if I want more replicas of RabbitMQ I
could change this if I want to change
the default username I could change that
to there's some quick links to the user
guide and tutorials here but let's just
go ahead and deploy this so what's
happening here is we're essentially
pushing that configuration to the
kubernetes api the same way you would do
it with the command-line tool like helm
at this point the application is all the
resources have been created in
kubernetes and it's just waiting for a
few pods to be created so I'm going to
go ahead and shortcut this and jump over
to the in-progress
installation here see so we can see some
components are still pending but
actually it's just waiting for a few
pauses to be created in the stateful set
so things should be like more or less
working now already so just to show you
what we have here so there's no external
IP address for this rabbitmq cluster and
that's probably a good idea you don't
want to be exposing your back-end
services to the Internet if you don't
have
- but just to show you that this is
working we can do a quick little port
forwarding here assuming this works so
here's the service where the admin
console is being exposed this is a neat
trick in the console you can actually
set up port forwarding from your browser
to an IP address inside the cluster okay
cross your fingers here all right so
that's the admin console but wait I
don't have the user name and password
but thankfully I just go back to the
application resource and find them
easily here so the username is rabbit
and the password here is gibberish we
generated that so that it would be a
secure out-of-the-box and I don't know
why it's saying that because the login
actually succeeded and here are all the
nodes and there's nothing running in the
queue but that's there you have it
alright let's switch back to the slides
now yeah so at this point we're just
gonna and take questions if I could
invite Ken and Conrad back onto the
stage
[Music]